DECADES OLD.
NASA CALLING THE NEED FOR NEW
SPACE SUITS CRITICAL.
KRISTEN FISHER IS OUT FRONT.
>> Reporter: EUROPEAN SPACE
AGENCY ASTRONAUT WAS WRAPPING UP
A SEVEN-HOUR LONG SPACE WALK
OUTSIDE THE INTERNATIONAL SPACE
STATION WHEN WE NOTICED WATER
LEAKING INTO HIS HELMET.
>> I THINK WE SHOULD ACCELERATE
THE STEPS TO GET HIM OUT OF THE
SUITS HERE.
>> Reporter: THEY GOT HIM OUT
BUT THE INCIDENT WAS SIMILAR TO
WHAT HAPPENED TO AN ITALIAN
ASTRONAUT BACK IN 2013.
>> I FEEL A LOT OF WATER ON THE
BACK OF MY HEAD.
>> Reporter: WATER FROM THE
COOLING TUBES INSIDE THE SPACE
SUIT WAS LEAKING INTO HIS HELMET
AND HE ALMOST DROWNED.
>> FOR A COUPLE OF MINUTES THERE
I EXPERIENCED WHAT IT'S LIKE TO
BE A GOLDFISH IN A FISH BOWL
FROM THE POINT OF VIEW OF THE
GOLDFISH.
>> Reporter: IT'S A NIGHTMARE
SCENARIO ACCORDING TO A FORMER
NASA ASTRONAUT WHO BECAME THE
FIRST SPACE SUIT ENGINEER AT
SPACE EX.
>> YOU CAN'T BREATHE AND TAKE
THE HELMET OFF.
YOU'RE IN A BAD, BAD PLACE.
IT GOT VERY SERIOUS.
>> Reporter: NASA HAS STOPPED
ALL SPACE WALKS AT THE
INTERNATIONAL SPACE STATION
UNTIL THE SPACE SUIT IS RETURNED
TO EARTH LATER THIS MONTH FOR AN
INCEPTION.
EVEN IF IT'S FIXED, THE
UNDERLYING PROBLEM IS THAT THESE
SPACE SUITS ARE DECADES OLD AND
THERE'S NOT MANY LEFT.
>> THAT BIG WHITE SPACE SUIT HAS
HERITAGE THAT GOES BACK TO
APOLLO, PRE-1975.
THE HELMET IS THE SAME AS THE
HELMET WE WORE ON THE APOLLO
SUITS.
>> Reporter: NASA KNOWS IT'S A
PROBLEM.
>> IT'S CRITICAL TO HAVE A SUIT
THAT WORKS FOR EVERYONE.
>> Reporter: NASA IS PARTNERING
WITH TWO COMMERCIAL COMPANIES TO
DEVELOP ITS NEXT GENERATION
SPACE SUITS BUT THOSE WON'T BE
READY UNTIL AT LEAST 2025.
>> NASA HAS GOTTEN QUITE GOOD AT
KEEPING THESE OLD CLUNKERS
RUNNING.
I THINK NASA HAS A REALLY
CAPABLE TEAM THAT WILL KEEP
THESE SUITS GOING AS LONG AS
THEY HAVE TO.
BUT THE RIGHT THING